I am a tree I'm a DJ on yacht week
yeah week is amazing like as a DJ it's
one of the best experience that I had my
life I grew up in Cairo being from Cairo
affected me with a lot of Arabic
melodies and my tunes and I loved it and
the crowd had loved it too I started
with doing my birthday party and I
invited all my friends from the first
time it was sold out and then second
time was sold out as well and here we
are it used to be one of my dreams to
play from the yacht week I'm Egyptian
I'm Muslim so I never drank in my life
and I feel really good about it and it's
not difficult at all because you have to
concentrate when you're DJing you have
to be like very sharp what you're doing
because one mistake party's over
I start my day with my coffee pairing
some music you do some mashup sand that
you can just jump in a boat to meet the
people of that week so I'm gonna take
you to a tour in the crew boat sometimes
the DJ stay there it's my breath
living around the
this is where we dine a while this is
the boat playing for a week is an
experience it's all about music it's not
only a set you're throwing and then
you're leaving but you're staying with
them for a week the most requested song
of course is this procedure I almost say
yes by never play the a week is amazing
why you meet people from all over the
world with different tastes play what
you like do I you feel on the state
follow your heart
what you really want to play
[Music]